welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz today i'm
really excited to be joined by elliot
milton who is the vp at levin group the
levin group have four brands under the
group storm two three four and five that
all operate in the fence fintech markets
green tech markets retail tech and
health tech markets
elliot kickstarted his recruitment crew
with faden in 2013 where he progressed
from graduate to executive director
within eight years
in that time he predominantly worked in
switzerland to start but then from 2017
he's been based in dallas where he then
founded the dallas office and later sat
on the u.s board for texas and south
for faded after a long and successful
career with faden elliot has now joined
the 11th group to spearhead their us
footprint as a brand
just a couple of weeks ago
they launched in the us where they went
from zero on the ground to 70 people in
one day and they now have huge ambitions
to continue to grow the u.s side of the
business which elliot is going to be
hugely involved in so uh elliot thanks
for you for joining us on the pod all
the way from the u.s
there will be people like i said to you
in preparing for this outside looking
and going how the hell is he how the
hell have these guys hired 60 people and
how many of them are actually going to
be there in two weeks time couple of
days time all these things right but
where we like to start which is probably
a question that you guys have thought a
lot about with particularly the amount
of people you're hiring is like what
what what do you believe are the sort of
common characteristics and traits that
you really think make up a highly
successful recruitment consultant in
today's market
i think it's a good question i think
when we interviewed when we set out to
interview i think this was the one thing
we had to unpack and really discover
because you waste a lot of time if you
hire the wrong people so i think the
cool thing about recruitment is it
doesn't really matter what background
what education or anything you have it's
not based on that at all so you look at
half the office here you have people
with meteorology degrees law degrees
philosophy degrees all great recruiters
but look at their resumes you're like
they don't match at all they're
completely different people so it does
as you say come completely down to
characteristics and for me
it's quite commonplace i watch some of
your other podcasts as well and i think
everyone says roughly around the same
thing because it makes sense but i think
number one i look for is um resilience
so i always need some form of example
from someone at the time they failed and
it can be small it can be huge but i
think what's really important coming
into this job is having some muscle
memory of failure and then what came
after that so what lessons you learned
how you changed the way you did
something because you and i both know
this job is all about failing every
single day learning from it doing it
again not giving up so i think proof of
this and an example of this is something
i look for in every grad interview that
i do if someone says i've never failed
one i don't believe them but two they're
gonna have a pretty hard ride joining
this uh this type of career because you
you start knowing nothing and the only
way you really progress is by doing it
wrong being told hey change this up and
then just learning by doing so i think
resilience is key because that's what
you'll have to contend with in your
first couple months and probably year in
recruitment is is
making mistakes and having things go
wrong i think number two is
emotional intelligence so this job's all
about speaking to people connecting
people if you don't like speaking to
people or
talking to different people
understanding one person is very
different from the next you've got to
sell in a slightly different way or talk
to them in a slightly different way
you're going to struggle with this job
and i think recruitment is slowly like
morphing into more of an email writing
type thing rather than when i started
where it was just like pound the phone
get get on the phone just call
switchboards i think now in the techy
age rat it's it's harder to pound
switchboards where most your clients
might not even have a switchboard so i
think maybe it's less important just by
selling with your words but also now on
email but i think emotional intelligence
knowing your audience is also key um i
think those are those are the two main
ones i think i actually look for um
outside of the are you competitive like
this is a sales job one like this is not
hr
um
this is not a form of other consulting
this is sales you have to want to be
number one hate being number two um but
also do you understand that working
together is key to building a business
and for us especially we can't have a
bunch of like
sales people who just want to be number
one and not help the wider cause we have
to have people that buy into the vision
that want to help each other and grow
the company because they know if they do
that they'll be more successful for it
um so i think yeah resilience emotional
intelligence competitiveness um
but also just a buy-in to a wider vision
and want to be part of something special
um in our case anyway where we know
we're not going to be 60 people for a
while like i'm going to hire
20 30 more people in a month so these
people will only be new for uh for a
month or so so i think those are the
things i look for um but apart from that
it's a really cool career where to be
honest it doesn't matter what the resume
or tv says it's purely based on the
personality interview when i when i when
i speak to them like i'm never gonna
know if someone's gonna be a good
recruiter to just looking at their
background um which is why i love this
sort of thing i get to work with
different people from different
backgrounds who all bring different
characteristics but i think yeah
resilience and emotional intelligence
are are the key things i love it and
then because i know see faden obviously
typically known for hiring grads so just
curious obviously you you're a graduate
yourself
like if you look at who elliot was when
you graduated and then the the sort of
huge amount of people that you saw that
are graduates i know obviously there's
nuances here because it's in america i
don't know any differences that you see
there or because i know like people were
you know saying ex like people who are
this age are more like this or i don't
know any any sort of things that you've
noticed or picked up on would you say
i i i think that so when i started i i i
can't really remember the the segway
from the so i did a law degree and i was
like i don't want to be a lawyer i um
worked in a law firm for a bit too slow
too boring nothing like the degree
itself so i i then was in that like
random period where you don't really
know what you want to do but you kind of
know what you want out of a career and i
just wanted to load the money like if i
look back at like my main motivations it
was it was money um
and i think that that still rings
through now i think the money motivated
individuals who are commercially aware
would tend to do well in recruitment and
like it but i think
the it's it's still similar when i look
at these grads and look at myself i see
a lot of them and me um and i i think
that uh comparing actually different
places i've worked has been the most
interesting so switzerland compared to
america or dallas is the polar opposite
of like the grad population or people
that you just hire in europe in
switzerland you tend to get like people
who are like two three jobs in people
with master's degrees where you wouldn't
really tend to look at that in the u.s
you tend to look at fresh grads um and
it's a different type of model um i
think in the u.s people like tend to
look at recruitment as an actual career
right yeah yeah totally
yeah and then and then yeah like it's
definitely true like the the grabs here
are
their family have been in sales they
want to be in sales they know what
recruitment is their friends do it um
which lends to a different population
and probably more people to choose from
compared to a uk where the rep is pretty
bad in a switzerland where like they can
get a banking job and on 100k base
straight away so why would they take the
risk on a high commission lower-based
job like recruitment so there's
different there's definitely different
um populations of grads uh to go for
that i've seen kind of and gone full
circle but for me the us has been the
most successful place to really kind of
drive the grad model and really scale
fast just because one there's loads more
people but two the career is seen as
probably more of a career than just a
stock gap just to make some money
quickly and then go off and do something
they really wanted to do um which is
good and i think that's why i'm still
here because i see the ability to scale
is just massive yeah yeah easier it
might be when you go for the game yeah
so just final thing again curious like
because you said resilience right which
obviously really common words like would
you say like there's different ones that
people use right snowflake generation
these things would you say people more
soft
i i think it's different right like i i
think the the way that recruitment is
now is not the same as it was when i
started in terms of like the skill sets
and what's driven on desk and the
environment i think it changed with the
generation i don't think it's
i think it's just different i think that
probably if you go back 20 years and
look at how salespeople did their job
it'd be different from my when when i
started then it's different to now so i
think not if not different in a bad way
like just different and you have to also
think that the clients are changing as
well like clients are very different now
than they were and candidates and they
were when i started like
you can't sell in the same way and i
think
covert accelerated the fact of like
using video calls everyone now calls
with the video so you have to be better
at that than when i started no one even
thought about doing a video cause very
very rare like it was all over phone or
like face to face so i think you just
got to be ready for that change and just
understand that the world has changed as
well and changed with it and not just
keep driving the what what ten years ago
now because it won't work and i think
that's the key thing that i've seen is
just staying with the times and if the
grad says hey we should uh we should get
a tick tock and start doing some
recruitment and and like some tick tock
so i'm like i don't really know what i'm
i'm a
generation that's like that's not really
me but it works now so you've got to go
with it and
make it work but i just think it's
different now the whole the whole world
of recruitment's different so it's not
worse it's just yeah you can't be stuck
in the past now i think you stopped the
game yeah no yeah i think different is
right i think the way that i think about
i'm 28 so i i was in 1993 right so i was
like on the cusp of like i grew up
knocking for my friends doing these
things and then i think i had got my
first mobile in like year six at school
so like i sort of had a bit of both if
you get what i mean and i've sort of
been on the journey but i feel like i've
spoke to this about my friends like
we're talking about resilience and it
being different but if i went through
school now and i had to also deal with
social media like that is a whole
different
like world of resilience you know i'm in
even though i might be on my phone more
or i'm not spending as much time like
calling people that are all these things
i just feel like it like you said it is
different i think we can be very
nostalgic around how it used to be and
drive that and this is what it needs to
be and people that aren't like that
they're just softer these days and these
things but i would probably argue that
to get through school now
and
have to deal with social media probably
more resilient i would say in my opinion
because that would have been [ __ ]
difficult going through that with all
that to deal with as well no i agree
they come they're sick skinned like
these people like these people although
they might not smash the phones every
day they definitely have gone through
some stuff that makes them good
recruiters and thinks the english is
different right like you said i i
definitely agree having seen them come
in and do well in recruitment in a
slightly different way
like you you it works like you just have
to yeah roll with the times and and
it'll be different in ten years again
where there'll be different ways of
recruiting you've got to got to be uh be
ready for that change and embrace yeah i
love it so look i i wanna i wouldn't
really dig into how the hell you you
guys have fought about and executed sort
of hiring such a a big group of people
and the strategy behind it and what
you're excited about so let's just let's
just sort of focus on fading for a
second
so
so i guess the first thing that i i'm
really curious about and i know other
people listen to this would be
like how how the hell did elliot adapt
with moving to switzerland recruiting in
switzerland like what what was that like
uh very difficult um it wasn't like i
came out of university being like
recruitment's but it'll be easy well
like i'm really good i really didn't do
that well in my first six months i i
i struggled one with
the culture differences so like
switzerland was a very different culture
to
um aberdeen so i went to university in
scotland so like i went from scotland to
switzerland in a week and then was flung
into a different culture where i had to
recruit finance and accounting in the um
in kind of germany switzerland region so
very very different job very different
types of people um
which took some time to kind of get to
know how to speak to them how to react
how to live in a different place
so i think yeah i'd be lying to say that
it was easy it was great everything went
well day one i i wasn't that recruitment
story i was the one where
plenty of times i probably thought this
isn't for me i'm gonna move back to the
uk and do something else where my
friends are and and kind of do a job
where i thought that i was doing a bit
better or was a bit easier or a bit more
95 but i had loads of days like that any
any person who's been in recruitment for
nine ten eleven years plus and he says
it's not a whole time and they never
thought about quitting is 100 lying uh
but i my first six months it was tough
but i looked back at that time and that
probably made me
um made me kind of set me up for for
what i what was to come in terms of
leadership and moving around the world
and things like that um so i look back
at it fondly but it was tough like i
think there isn't really a secret source
to make it work i think the one thing i
didn't do was give up both my family a
lot about like they gave me some like
good motivation words like you're good
enough don't give up yet um i think that
was that was definitely key but really
just me looking around the company and
thinking i'm better than some of these
people it will come i'm gonna keep
beating the people around me on the key
kpis like doing the basics really well
eventually it will come um and it did
eventually it just took me six to twelve
months to really get it in a different
country um but once i got it then it
started to get really good um and and
you start to really push on but it was
tough like it was not easy but 100 worth
it and anyone thinking about should i
take
should i take that risk move to a
different country i've never been there
before yeah just do it like it's 100
worth it it's tough but like if you
really want to kind of climb up that
ladder quickly you've got to take those
risks and uh i look back and it was it
was yeah because that's extreme man
because like like you said went from
university in aberdeen
and i'm assuming like he was leading
some sort of you like uni life
i don't know how i like you know i mean
whatever that looked like going out of
your mates getting drunk watching them
tell you not and then just flung
yourself straight into
a different country and a different
world of work
um i guess what would be interesting
just to get a bit practical for the sec
for a second
like i'm sure you've you've picked up on
this but i'm speaking to multiple
recruitment companies now the
a lot of their um business and the most
profitable part of their businesses um
are serving companies outside of the uk
um and a lot of them are in are in
europe and a lot more people going over
to the us
so i guess particularly around like as
you said like picking up on the nuances
of like
culture and these things for anyone
listening to this that um actually
really is excited with the opportunity
of um getting into a business and
recruiting people in germany berlin
maybe the us or getting over there like
further people that might be really
concerned of like what the hell is it
gonna like what am i gonna have to get
grips of really quickly around calling
elliott in germany the i don't know i
might annoy him i don't know like
picking up on like i don't know what
helps you speed up that process of
understanding what flies in switzerland
what doesn't i don't know and anything
in there that looking in hindsight could
help people
um i think it's it comes back to like
how you learn recruitment making
mistakes and i think you you kind of
pick up quite quickly like when you when
you say something and then you get shot
down or when you send a type of email or
you push too hard you tend to like
realize when you push the boundary okay
i got to take it back a step and i think
in europe that was key for me i think
there it's much less of a
london or like east coast us salesy
culture where you push push push it's so
relationship driven and you really have
to
like go for coffees with people get to
know them like really delve deep into
kind of the the personal side of your
clients and candidates more so than just
saying here's a great job here's a great
candidate pay me the money let's go on
let's move on it's so relationship
driven it took me some time to
understand that but i think what working
in switzerland did for me at the start
was teach me how to really work well
with clients and get to know them a lot
better and be way less transactional i
think a lot of recruiters who come from
bigger cities who have just done
um recruitment in those big cities where
it is more transactional they they kind
of send canada get off do deal do it
again and they don't really get to know
them probably struggle then to flip to a
more relationship driven uh culture and
i'd say the south of the us is that like
the south of the us is very much a
switzerland in terms of a getting to
know you culture like they want to work
with you rather than the company and i
think yeah you learn by like pushing the
boundaries and then kind of walking it
back a bit but i think it's so different
in so many different places but i think
switzerland compared to like a new york
you have to act completely different to
um to clients and candidates to get what
you want um
so yeah i don't think there is like a
one answer this is what you do sort of
thing i think it's about like pushing
the boundaries all the time like don't
don't shy away from trying to
prove your worst new deals but like when
you think that you push too far maybe
you need to back it up and do it in a
different way in certain cultures in
certain certain countries especially as
an english person like english person
doing recruitment anywhere like they
already think you're like a bit
especially salesman because there's so
many english recruiters everywhere so
you've got to prove that you're not the
same as the rest and you understand the
culture and the way of working
alongside giving them good candidates
and good services so when did the us
opportunity come on your radar then
because from what i can see i went over
there and
towards the end of 2017 like when did
that come on your radar
yeah so i i've been in switzerland for
four years or so i never really planned
to be there for that long it wasn't
really my life goal to live in zurich
for the rest of the rest of my time so i
kind of got to the point where i'd gone
from graduate to head of the office um
and the one thing i didn't see is the
scale in zurich it's super expensive no
business is going to be 200 people in
zurich it makes zero sense so i quickly
thought okay so if i want to keep
growing and progressing i'm going to
have to go somewhere else in the
business and i don't want to go to an
office that's already big and already
has 100 people i want to start something
myself
and for me the us was where we were
making the most money the biggest deals
the biggest opportunities so i asked
okay where where are we opening next
what's the next office we're going to
open and i would love to be a part of it
i'd love to go out there and do it i
don't really mind where it is i'm super
flexible and it just so happened that we
didn't have a presence or then didn't
have a presence at the time in texas so
i said yeah that's i'm good i'll go
there i've never been to texas in my
life it's not like the holiday
destination number one for anyone going
to um the us so i took the job without
having
dallas or texas um i thought that it was
going to be and i thought it'd be way
more texan than it is like i had like
hats i had like guns in my head but then
when i'm here i'm like you know what
this is just a normal fast-growing city
multicultural like easy place to live if
you want cowboys and guns you can get it
but like that's not what the city is so
yeah i'd never never been here took the
job said okay cool i'll do the dallas
office um
relocated myself to
dallas um opened the office with i think
it was like six of us in a room with no
windows in a regis office as a lot of
companies um and that was the start of
the story so there wasn't a like reason
for me really going to dallas pacific or
texas yeah you wanted the opportunity
led thing where i wanted to grow
something and for me it had to be
somewhere new so i could prove to myself
and others i can build it from scratch
and not just be there as the grad who's
going into it um and also somewhere i
can scale and the us for me was where i
saw the most scalability uh at the time
so that was really the main the main
reason that i kind of moved
what do you think you showcased to
because i'm sure there would have been
another i know you said there's a few
other people but i'm sure there would
have been a number of people that
would have wanted that opportunity like
people listening to this probably want
opportunities like what you're talking
about what do you think you showcase to
give the people whoever it was sort of
enough trust to go you know what we're
going to put elliott down as one of the
first on the ground
i think one one thing is and and what
lots of companies do well what we're
trying to do here what fade and
definitely uh preached was the organic
growth piece i was very young in quite a
big role and i proved kind of that i
could handle it i didn't give up like
zurich didn't go particularly well all
the time it was a it was a hard business
to run it was a very different culture
so i think showcasing that resilience
again and showing that like look it
didn't go well but he kept on building
it learned from his mistakes and then it
ended up a positive experience where we
made money um in zurich and the office
was successful i think going through
that transition of like again failure
learning and then making it good was was
important and i think
yeah that that's probably the major
thing that that i that i showed is the
progression from graduate to
um to direct uh making mistakes learning
and then wanting to take a risk
in my career to to further it i think
that's what all these businesses have
grown by people saying hey i'm putting
my hand up let me go over there and and
i prove i'll prove it to you that it's
the right decision in most cases the
organic pro model does work um so i
think i was just another example of that
where i put my hand up after proof
proving its own and uh took the risk and
it already been proven with other people
moving around that it does work if you
back the person um internally to go do
something like that so
yeah and it did work in the end like it
does definitely uh definitely work but i
think proving yourself going through the
tough times and uh backing yourself um
was kind of the key thing i think anyone
can do it there's no there's no special
thing about me i think i just i i i
definitely just worked really hard
learned from my mistakes and took risks
and never got comfortable um because i'm
just the type of person that if it's not
difficult and if i'm not learning then i
want to go try something else or do
something different and continually push
myself i i i'm not one for staying in
the same position for five years if
because it's comfortable like that's not
me so
yeah just always looking for that next
step or next opportunity that that's
just so you mentioned that
what's your experience being of imposter
syndrome
like
if at all um
i don't think i i i i don't think there
is i don't think there has been anything
to be honest
would you not think i don't know like
looking around like [ __ ] now
four years ago i was in aberdeen like
doing this now i'm here
you grow up really fast i think in
recruitment you're like when you're
pushed in the right way in a company
where like you are pushed every day to
do what like my motto is like if someone
says okay i want to get 20 interviews
they get 20 interviews the next like
where's 25 where's 30 like if you're
constantly pushing that way and
you see the results and you're a
motivated person like you tend to forget
quite quickly like how old you are and
like how long you've been doing it like
i feel kind of old in recruitment now
but i've not even like what i've got
nine ten years in my career in general
that's that's all i've got and i feel
like i'm kind of a little bit old now
but in reality age is just a number i
think it was for me it was just
constantly trying to overtake people in
the company and proving myself that got
me to where i was so i forgot how old i
was i just purely went on
merit and if i was doing better i knew i
was going to get the role and just kept
growing from that from that uh
standpoint so i think i've just always
been the person who's like never really
talked about age or i don't care about
the people here either like if someone
comes in and does better than you then
they're gonna get the opportunity first
um and i think yeah it never really
stood out to me maybe when i look at it
later i'll be like crazy like i just
relocated the other side of the world
and it worked but at the time i was just
kind of living in the moment and i just
kept pushing myself and i didn't really
think oh i've only got four years doing
this like what the hell am i doing i'm
gonna i'm gonna [ __ ] this up and never
never came to my mind i just backed
myself um every every time um and hope
that it would well um so what what did
what did dallas look like for faith and
then before you left so obviously like
you said you got there it was like
what did it look like
yeah so i think it was probably between
like
30 and 35 people or so um with a few of
the brands present um in the office a
decent structure of kind of a middle
layer management and grads coming in um
so we got through kind of the the first
hump of getting it up and running in a
new area where we didn't really have a
ton of clients allison texas in the
south wasn't really a very kind of
highly touched market in the u.s for us
because we didn't have loads of people
at baden but we had um enough to do a
little bit in texas but really my remit
was to grow it further like make it
bigger it's a huge market so it was
tough at the start um to get going but i
think once we understood the way of
working target clients and market and
really drill down um we we did really
well like we were the best office in the
world one year i think the year before i
left in terms of uh performance so we
got up there in terms of a really really
successful office um but yeah once i let
it it was probably about six people and
then when i left mid-thirties or so um
so what what what so couple of things
then we'll move on to like the past
couple of months so firstly what were
what were some of the the sort of
challenges that you may be like i know
it seems like you just went straight
into it back to yourself but what were
some of the challenges on on that
journey that maybe you least expected
out of interest
um i think the
uh
good question i think the way of working
was different i think coming from yeah
the nuances of like
actually coming to terms with like yeah
texas was it more direct
it's more direct like it's more direct
you can be a bit more salesy compared to
switzerland so actually making that
transition and understanding how to sell
again for the right people and how to
talk in the right way and and recruit in
in a slightly different manner was
probably
the hardest thing but apart from that it
was all very similar like in terms of
like the how you do a deal yeah it
changed but it was the same same process
recruitment's the same
it was more of the nuances of culture
and then the nuances of hiring grads
because i was amazed as soon as i came
to the u.s how much better the graduates
were like no offense to the to no
offense to the the people i hired in
previous businesses but i think like i
said recruitment was front of mind they
wanted to sell they were fine to get on
the phone straight away they understood
things quickly and there was just a lot
more of them to go for you weren't kind
of you weren't kind of struggling to
find the masses to scale um so i think
all those things were different um but
uh
yeah it was what i wanted like the
challenge at the time was to do
something different so i went from one
side to the other which i knew it was
going to be different because i wanted
that and it was just yeah another learn
by doing situation make a few mistakes
don't make them again keep on moving
fast um and and that was love
so so um more more of a personal
question here and then i'm keen to talk
about the last couple of months like
i've spoken to a few people on this
podcast and and personally where as i
sort of highlighted earlier that like
more and more recruitment companies i
speak to have america on their business
plan and i think for the ambitious and
and for people like you and like the
general you've been on that's going to
be a really exciting opportunity and i
think a lot of people listening to this
will have that opportunity
and potentially given to them so the
personal question is like what's your
sort of advice for people it seems like
you just sort of
jump straight in but
like there definitely are challenges in
terms of relocating your life there that
maybe people don't anticipate like i've
got no [ __ ] friends um i'm not in a
relationship i've gone over here i
literally feel like i'm alone all i've
got is work i've it's been hard to
integrate into the culture
anything on that that sort of helped i
don't know because we've had people on
here before who did go to america is
exciting and just didn't quite work out
more of the personal side and it was
more challenging than anticipated
anything on that that could be helpful
for people
yeah i think so i think actually the
burden of this is on the leader of the
office to say there was to relocate
office and there was already a leader
there and a team there a burden of of
this is on the leader of that office for
sure one thing i made very very sure
when i hired anyone really but also the
masses that we've just hired right now
was keep it fun and keep things uh going
that are not work related so
making sure that and it's not just
drinking sodas and stuff but making sure
that you you have a committee of people
at the start we have something called
the culture committee here which we
started from
day one and they are really the drivers
of what we do outside of just uh
doing deals and i think once you give
that to the people and they decide what
the culture is like then i think for
people moving into that business they're
kind of part of something else they get
to go out and play sport with
people connections
yeah
100 if you don't build those social
connections you are going to struggle
because you're going to have those dark
days where you go home you've just lost
the yeah
and if there's no one to speak to go to
the gym with go for a drink like it will
be really really hard so i think making
a point to both be good at your job but
also get out there and speak to people
both colleagues but also like join
facebook groups like all of that stuff
like sounds basic but actually do it
yeah
commit to it because if you don't then
it can be a really really lonely place i
don't think i did that as well as i
could have in switzerland looking back i
think i could have got myself out there
and like stopped wearing just about work
every day and actually looked at like my
life outside of it and i think that's
led me to now making sure that day one
all of these grabs some of which have
never had a proper job before feel that
they're one at work like professional
environment we work hard but also
they're not alone loads of these people
have relocated here as well from other
states they know where the ships are
they know where they can go out like
that's important stuff that people
sometimes forget so i think less of a
burden on the person more of a burden on
the person who's getting this relocated
uh consultant or whoever whoever joining
but vital because if not people leave
like you'll you'll have people who just
could be the best recruitment consultant
but because you've not made the effort
and they feel like they're not at home
they're like
relocate back to my family um and that's
probably more on the manager than what
we're saying on the social scene
what was that how would you describe the
social scene and that like dallas and
the places you experienced for a uk
person like how would you describe it
it's great like i think that like the
social scene's very different in dallas
compared to other us cities it's very
spread out like there's not like one um
like main street that you go out every
time like there's very much pockets of
like different types of uh
like there's like one place that's
probably more edgy
place one place is a bit more like it's
very spread out everyone drives here so
don't come to dallas if you can't drive
because you'll struggle because there's
no real public transport it's all about
your car but i think the social seems
like any other like it's an up and
coming city where there is a ton of
people moving here every day so one
everything's quite new the nice thing
here is that it hasn't been here for 20
30 years there's apartment buildings
being built restaurants everything's
coming here so it's quite clean it's
quite new um but the social scene some
people might think it's not as fun as
the bigger new york or the bigger like
it's a fun for sure you just have to
come here to experience it and not um
just assume that just because it's newer
and in the south it's different i think
everyone that comes here is like i
didn't know dallas was like this before
i came here but now i want to live here
and that's that's the standard thing
everyone says before they're like nah
not dallas i'll go to la i'll go
somewhere else because they know it
because they've seen pictures but
dallas is still that kind of hidden gem
of a place and i think i got here before
obviously pre-covered before the past
before people started to relocate and it
took me probably a year or so to be like
you know what why would i live anywhere
else there's no income tax like i can
afford a nice place to live like it's
just an easier life um but it takes a
little time to get there um and you
definitely have to live it to believe it
like i i i can say all this but like
take a trip to an austin a dallas or
somewhere in texas and you'll see uh a
big difference in your in your thoughts
of where you want to live in the us if
you're thinking about it yeah i love it
so let's talk about the the past sort of
um um a couple of months then so i think
let's just dig into obviously yeah
outside looking in i think yeah hiring
huge amount of people at once like talk
to us and sort of break it down a bit
because i think this is what's really
unique about you guys when preparing for
this on like how
how you're thinking about how we can get
people up to speed and i think just to
frame this up why this is really
relevant right now and i'm sure you
picked up on this but every single
recruitment company right now is hiring
to keep up with their clients demands
now most companies that i speak to
having sort of little or no success
getting experienced recruiters through
the door because let's be honest like
with how boring the market is right now
you should be making some good money so
why you're leaving has got to be pretty
strong and these things so most
companies that we're speaking to that
we're working with are really back to
hiring that trainee grad level these
things right and for growing companies
and particularly small growing companies
and i'm sure you might have experienced
this in sort of pockets in your career
that can be really challenging these
people can take up loads of time some of
them may not work out and it can be
really difficult whereas obviously you
guys have gone well look instead of
instead of trying to get three four here
another five here another five there
you're gonna get a whole a huge sort of
nucleus and collectible people from day
one
and we're gonna get them up to speed
like talk to us about the strategy here
like because there's obviously a
strategy
yeah no for sure and this was kind of
the sell to me when i when i looked at
companies to join before i i chose this
opportunity this was the this was the
one thing that stood out to me because
of my experience of hiring pockets of
five 10 people and then like when you
thought about it and like decided it
wasn't that crazy actually it works by
just putting a few process things in
place so i think one don't underestimate
the the power of like passive learning
and people learning from each other by
doing the job i think that half the
stuff that is taught in this office
isn't by me or the leaders it's by
someone listening to someone else asking
oh what happened there that didn't sound
so good what did you do and then either
doing it themselves or not so i think
doing that times 60 rather than times 10
means it's just a ton more learning
going on in the room when you hire the
right people i think it still comes back
to hiring that right person and not just
thumbs on seats um so i think that's one
thing and two i think the structure that
we put in play here with not an emphasis
on a vp or a leader doing everything
from business development training i.t
um like commercial stuff everything you
can think of but we actually have fired
a few different people per pod who take
on three or four tasks every day and
that's all they do they do they run
really really fast in a small box let's
say so you have a commercial person who
is attached to a storm who just runs the
um client side of things so make sure
that we're working jobs with the right
firms we're working jobs in the right
area we're making use of clients that we
can do two three four deals with because
one thing grabs don't know is that part
that well they've not really dealt with
clients before so there needs to be some
sort of check of terms of like okay if
you're going to spend your time on this
it's right we've got terms they're at
the right level and also is there an
opportunity for other businesses to
leverage on your work um so we have that
person in play that person is an ex
recruiter that's a great experience who
understands recruitment but really likes
the client side doesn't really want the
delivery once the client-side um you
also have a people operations manager
who is really a performance manager so
not an l d trainer they're not in
classrooms every day they're not doing
that but they are performance managing
those grabs making sure that one at the
start they know how to use the system
they know like what their area is what
recruitment is like the whole process
but then once they get going they're
really there to identify trends and
analyze performance to make sure that we
make the middle piece here of people the
best and we make the best even better
and we help the ones who are not doing
well in the right areas um but they are
there doing their job day to day in a
team of thirty and that's always
thirteen work jobs they don't try and
get on clients they said team of 30.
yeah per brand so essentially the 60 we
hired were split between storm 2 30
storm three yeah so you've essentially
in my office right now you've got two
brands a team of 30 grads each so within
that brand you have a gp um a people
operations manager universal so when you
split that down and you think okay 30
people but you have three people who are
managing that process that's 10 people
per per person anyone can manage 10
people but one person can't manage the
grads at one go so we put a structure in
place to allow for faster growth and
we've hired people who are very
motivated by the area either an
ex-recruiter who wants to train an
ex-recruiter who wants to do clients or
an ex-recruiter who knows how to lead a
team knows how to close a candidate and
they just like i said run really fast
and the smaller and then you load the
grabs in and then it works a lot faster
than saying because if i said if i
couldn't do this myself i couldn't be
the one person with 60 grads it would
just it wouldn't work but once you put
the right people in play and then hire
the very best grads you start to see the
whole thing explode and move a lot
faster and that's really it's not a
secret source it's just finding ways to
fine-tune what's been done in the past
and make it move a whole lot faster so
you're not relying on one person to do
everything um
so that's in a general terms kind of
how we manage to hire that many people
and that they all actually get the
support that they need because support
is the key thing um and i think that
what what levin group did before i
arrived and what we're doing now was
fine tune that and make sure the model
and the process was correct before we
hire the grad so that has to be there
and set in terms of you have those
people in play yeah you put the grabs
underneath but once those people are in
play and they're motivated compensated
in the right way and ready to rock then
it's actually a lot easier than one
would expect to see 60 people walk in
the door um on one day uh which was an
awesome experience but i think i was
saying like it wasn't like stressful
because i knew the process would work
and i knew that the plan was in place in
terms of people knew what they were
doing what they were responsible for um
it was just difficult because yeah you
you tend to just have there's a lot of
work like you're flying around you're
walking around all the time
but it's it's fun at the same time but
it works like they're all still here and
um
we're already seeing successes uh from
from the amount of people we've hired so
yeah it's all down to that like prep
work and and process that you put in
beforehand knowing that everyone is very
very kind of
very um aware of what their role is
every day and they don't want to do
someone else's right yeah i think they
do their role really well the thing
that's unique about that is won the sale
but i think as you all know
in recruitment and growing recruitment
companies it's very common that elliot
and elliot might be the the commercial
person in that setup but elliott also is
expected to do the training to do the
the things so then all of a sudden like
you said they're not running really fast
in a small box they're trying to run
fast in a really big box right so i
think that that's unique thing which i
really like so couple of things here
that um i'm just just just sort of uh
curious about so very typical for a
recruitment company although it does
seem like shifting right uh shifting now
where people really have sort of um
if you want to be like a recruiter in a
delivery role they have sort of career
progression plans for that and just that
it's not just 360 like how how have you
set up the on the actual recruiters
themselves are they going straight into
candidates obviously i know you've got
that commercial person that winning
business like are they just on the
candidate side initially what does that
look like
so there are 360 consoles so everyone we
hire is not delivery candidate focus
everyone picks up the phone emails
clients candidates from day one we're
not going to hire any 180 consultants
the the commercial person is there
really to
pick up on work that has already been
done by the consultant and make sure
it's at the right level and they're
helping out to maintain the right client
relationships and and really kind of
consultants get the bikes commercial
will convert those fights into jobs vp
will then help consultant to place that
job close candidates and
people op person will train them to do
all of those parts really well and use
the system properly so everyone who
comes in and is not sharing deals is not
like doing just hands at work or
headhunting they are in an area in
specific niche but they do everything
like that they're a complete 360
recruiter they just have different
people to go to um for help in different
ways to make the whole thing yeah i got
it um and then what what have been what
have been some of the common trends so
far then on the performance side out of
interest that you might have been
surprised by or interested by
um so i think what three weeks in um i
think one thing i've been surprised with
is just how these people so far have
picked up like
what how one thing connects to the next
at volume and doing it really quickly
because no one really no one knew what
recruitment was before this no one does
and i think what i've been surprised is
we've gone from 60 people having no idea
to 60 people um getting interviews we've
had a few retainers signed already with
new clients that been picked up by these
graduates who didn't even know what they
were doing three weeks ago like we've
seen some really good successes already
and i think i was probably surprised
maybe i shouldn't have been but i was
surprised how quickly
the graduates picked it up um and
started to show value really quickly and
they're just really hungry like we have
people in here who are super hungry to
do well see the massive um opportunity
they have because they joined a company
that was zero people when they joined
and will be like i have plans to i want
to make this us business one thousand
people by the time i leave this country
so if these people are coming in day one
they know the opportunity that they can
get to open an office lead a big team
and really progress if they work hard so
i've been just surprised with um how
quickly they've really kind of hopped on
the train of recruitment and and got
going um and uh yeah like so far so far
so good it's i don't want to jinx it i
don't want to walk out and then see see
some people uh make mistakes and do and
do stuff and walk out but so far touch
wood uh
it it's gone well and the process has
worked exactly how it how it should and
then as part of the process here because
i know this is what people be interested
in as well
obviously i know you guys are taking an
entire different approach and more of
like a sort of hockey stick growth curve
right but like
like how have you guys thought about or
like what have you
not necessarily budgeted for but like
what's the what are you expecting or
what did you plan for the maturity curve
to be in terms of like if we get elliot
in tomorrow
we probably suspect if things go well
that he should be paying for his desk
within six months easily and i don't
know like how i don't know how have you
guys thought what was the mindset there
so i think one thing i think uh people
don't sometimes or they why would they
they don't assume they assume we're not
making any money they're not we're we're
losing money because we're growing so
quickly so we're actually not we're
making money we're we're we we have
ebitda that we're reinvesting into the
business and we are now profitable so
it does work but yeah obviously you
don't make profit day one if you hire 60
people who don't know what they're doing
like you're gonna you're gonna lose some
money before making it but i think that
the kind of first six months a key and
then after that six months you have such
a critical mass doing well in a good
market with good leaders but
you hockey stick a whole lot faster than
if you do it in 510 uh people um intake
so yeah one definitely we're making
money as a business globally which uh is
awesome and we're reinvesting it
straight away to continue to grow it's
showing which shows what we're doing
works because i think yeah sometimes if
you hire 60 people you can lose money
pretty quickly with the wrong model but
we're cash positive and
we are just now just repeating the model
like we know what works we just have is
it the six months
six months typically that you've got is
it like this because that is quite
common like is it you're like this is
the yeah that's where we're going they
they should if we've got the right
person then six months they should be
paying for themselves and then and more
and then obviously continue to grow is
that typically what you budgeted
if i look at a time scale of like grad
to
successful i think like the first six
months of vital i think the first two
months or so like making mistakes not
really making much money but i think
that then you're set up for success in
kind of months three to nine to twelve
where you start to be more consistent
understand the job connect the dots so i
would say within the first six months
you see a massive um skill increase from
not knowing what they're doing trying to
do deals but in the first i reckon it's
going to be even faster judging on what
i've seen so far in terms of opportunity
to make money in the right areas work
jobs quickly sign retainers really
quickly as well so i reckon if i'm gonna
say my team is probably gonna watch it i
reckon that three months is where like i
want them to start being consistent um i
want to see a deal and i want to start
to see those dots connected and then if
you can get to that period then that
yeah from there you you will make money
the deal sizes our average fee is
probably around
35 38 000 um dollars so like once you
start doing those consistently you will
get money what's the what's the
performance output expectation in the
first year
it's so in terms of like first yeah like
yeah what what no yeah what are you
hoping like what have you expected
um of of people
so i think i think an easier way to say
i think in the first uh three months
you're learning you're not gonna make
any money i think from month three to
twelve what i would be going for is one
deal a month i'd be consistently trying
to do one perm deal a month in that area
um some people will end up doing a lot
more some people will struggle for a bit
more but then pick it up um but i think
consistency is key and i think after
that training period is off and the kind
of wheels are off i think one deal a
month is what i would look for um so
yeah one deal a month averaging around
30 35 k um would be what i would expect
uh for kind of the first year over kind
of the nine months yeah
yeah
because because may i know i know it's a
different right but
obviously because i'm in the
learning development conversation every
single day like i've sat down with
multiple companies where first year
expectation is 75 grand
yeah so that's why because again this is
what people were interested in right
outside looking in it's like well what
are their targets like what like all
these types of things what they expect
do you know what i'm in because like if
i ask you that and you're like well we
expect that yeah and that's just
interesting
yeah i think it's like it depends like
it's all a belief system thing about
like uh what whatever like
i think if you say 75 is good then 75 is
good like they don't really know what
what good looks like so they'll take
whatever you say is that if you say 500
is good then some people probably hit
500 some people won't come anywhere near
but at least you kind of keep raising
that bar in the right place because
we're here to grow quickly do really
well i want people to make a lot of
money so i want to set punchy goals
because i've seen one it works i've come
through that environment where there was
always someone better than me and always
somewhere i could i could uh i could
improve um
but i think yeah i think that's low if i
was to if i was if someone wants to say
that to me i push back for sure and be
like uh look at the people that have
been in the business already in london
that started who have done for 500k in
their first year with the same amount of
tools and experience you have that's
that's the goal that's where you need to
get to i think once you start having the
belief system shift because some more
people have done it and then they come
in seeing the numbers already been done
then you just have to hire the right
people who take that and just just want
to drive it um so it would shift from
company to company because certainly
finding one company might be really good
for what they want but for us
we want the we want people hitting the
56700k
and i think the people we hire those who
want to want to be the best recruiter in
their in in their in their area not not
not average and i'm one who will always
push someone to their absolute limit to
get together i need to get to um because
yeah i want to see future leaders and
people change their lives no i love it
you you guys are challenged in the state
it's quite right this is what this is
all about so i guess as we come to an
end here how how are we
how are we thinking about culture in in
this uh in this cocktail of scale and
and growth right because yeah how are
you i know you said you've got the
culture committee which i absolutely
love that so people come i'm assuming
completely dedicated to things like you
said what we're doing outside of work
what what are people telling us that
they need more help with what would be
great these things because that that can
also be something that people think a
lot about or worry about right how can
we make sure that we don't become a
business or to be known as like we hire
these young people and then we spit out
50 of them and that's a big part of why
recruitment doesn't get a good name
right so like how we think about culture
as as we grow this company
i think like if i look at my role and
what i want to um what might i think
there's two things that i have to do
really really well to succeed one of
which we've discussed hire the very best
people who fit the mold of a good
recruiter number two is make sure the
culture is set in a way where people are
worked hard they they do well they hit
targets that need to be hit they come to
work to
make lots of money compete grow their
career but also have fun with it i'm big
component of like coming to work laugh
have fun be open um and so i think the
culture of like competitive but
collaborative are the two words
if anyone asked me an interview like
what should the culture be both those
things not one or the other because if
you have competitive only then you just
have a bunch of individuals wanting each
other nobody does well you can't scale
but if you have collaborative only you
have a bunch of people who don't really
care about doing well and everyone's
happy but like no one's making any money
so i think both of them are important
and i think that's my job is to make
sure that
as we grow that doesn't dilute and
that's the one challenge that i think i
face uh over the next coming years is
making sure that when this office is 200
people soon it's still the same as it
was day one like the culture is still
there in in those collaborative
terms because if it is i know that i
will succeed so making it fun is number
one like the job is hard like this job
is difficult like there's so much
rejection it's not it's the hardest
sales job you do you're selling you're
selling people people do all sorts of
things you don't know about and so
you've got to make it fun you've got to
make sure that it's an open culture
where people are not scared to ask
questions not scared to ask their
colleague hey can you do this but also
their colleague will always help them
out and say hey yeah we're in this
together um for me
going on my years before this that is
what
i picked from like the different
businesses that i've run or been in that
i enjoyed most and what i wanted to put
into play here because yeah if the
culture sucks then like it doesn't
matter how good you are at hiring or how
much money there is in the market or how
how many clients are hiring you're not
gonna you're gonna do well like there's
enough choices for people to have in
terms of other companies so culture is
number one in terms of like what i've
tried to instill over the over the past
three or so weeks with these people um
and is extremely extremely i'm extremely
passionate about that side of it because
i've seen it go wrong in different
companies and like i don't want to be
that person i want to make sure that
people love to work here one because
they make loads of money and it's
successful but two they actually just
like to work um
and i'm still a big proponent of
in-office working as well like giving
flexibility but i think learning
recruitment
i think you you guys have one place you
guys have to lean and lean in and own
we're we're in we're an office first
company or like we've invested a lot in
our office experience which is why you'd
probably rather work here than uh like
the way that you're doing it
like imagine having to see imagine
having like 70 people join the zoom join
the the storm zoom like this storms even
call for day one i'll be [ __ ] chaos
so we've all been there actually on the
third day so um it's funny you said that
so the third day of uh operations here
so there was a huge storm in dallas um
and like i said at the start do you like
when they're storming
people forget how to drive to work and
stuff so we had to go forward for day
three and four um with 60 grads who had
been literally had just like picked up a
laptop and didn't know what they were
doing so we had to we had to make that
work for the first um
for the first week and it does work like
you can do it like again with the right
people doing the right things but is it
the best way to start a business to get
the results quickly i still don't
believe it is but i think i am a
believer that once you get over the
first pump of understanding what
recruitment is understanding your role
then flexibility is key like work from
home a day to a week it doesn't really
matter but yeah when you want to learn
recruitment quickly and we want to teach
you at scale and make
up then like where look i do look i
absolutely love your energy mate like
just can tell how passionate you are but
kudos to you on like just grabbing the
opportunity you've had with both hands
and making the most out of everything
but like where's um where's this
business going to be in another 18
months then mate
where where is it going to be
so i think my vision for the the uf
business will be um
i reckon 200 people in dallas all four
brands a new york office that will
launch uh that will launch in the next
three months um
a
west coast office and a southeast office
as well um
launched with 50 plus people um so
what's that i'd say 300 plus at least in
the us in 18 months uh probably more
across four offices would be
a good start to the us business um and a
good goal so we're not this is just the
start like i say to these people you're
going to be new in this business for two
months and then people are gonna start
asking you questions about what you're
doing and look for you for advice so
learn fast have fun with it and enjoy
like it's all about enjoying like not
many companies get to do something like
this um
not many grads get the opportunity to be
part of something like this so even for
me like like you said i'm pretty excited
for like i i um i'm enjoying what i'm
doing it's a challenge
but i know when i back the process so
the stress levels are relatively low but
the challenge is high and that for
so i think that's my vision um and for
people coming into the business like
what an opportunity like you could be a
grad one day and and two years later
you'd be a vp leading a team in a
different state and and that's what we
want like we don't hire senior people
outside of that really trio of
management everyone else is going to go
organically and and and really their own
destinies in their own hands because we
need to push them and get them there so
i'm super excited because
hopefully yeah i i back it for sure and
it's a fun ride um and it would be cool
to to do it again and and see what uh
see what the next 12 18 months looks
like but that's that's for me my my my
vision and what i'm trying to execute
and really what i'm living for over the
next elliot it's been an absolute
pleasure excited to see it from afar and
now we'll absolutely speak over it over
the next year or so
legend sounds good
thank